The Joe Rogan Experience
you want to know what's going to happen
yeah with what but with in this country
okay yeah yeah so you want to hear now
yeah yeah yeah yeah tap me in we're in
the Bolshevik War right now bro and
right now what's coming up is the all
the pride stuff is gonna be okay so I
had this woman come on my podcast her
name's Mel K and we've gotten in real
trouble on this show before because we
talked about this one family that I will
not name okay and every time we name
this family the four Tech Gods all came
down and just [__] my show yeah
hey I'm not saying their name bro I'm
trying to tank his own show yeah that's
how much he loves the Deep State yeah
so she comes out again we just mentioned
what happened on the show they do it to
us again they do it to us again we just
mentioned their name go you remember
when we talked about them and they took
it happens again damn so she so what are
they doing when this happened let me say
they do this to you what do they do to
you okay so on app so Apple Google
Twitter and Facebook all after me how so
like Shadow band suppression no no even
worse even worse so on uh on Apple they
listed my podcast that no one listened
to it for like like they showed nobody
listening to the podcast so they blocked
people from listening like when you go
to like see what you're down how your
your podcast is doing it listed nobody
like not just one episode
multiple episodes I got strikes and
deletes on my YouTube channel and all my
Facebooks I couldn't get into my
Facebook whoa
yeah so it
was what did you mention that this
family had done that's so egregious this
is funny because it involves it involves
something to Brian that basically this
family is so rich that people think that
the CFR is just basically their Board of
Trustees what's the other companies the
Seattle Foreign Relations oh oh sorry
they're your babysitters bro come on
yeah
yeah remember the ones who taught you
how to tie your [__] shoes my
favorite was Joe's like you don't
believe it's a conspiracy is because you
love your dad
okay Mel K comes on my show and she's
like and this is she goes I've been
talking to some people in the
intelligence and they go this gay pride
stuff is going away and the next thing
you're going to see
our immigration riots this is going to
be right around the next election so
hand to God we do this episode next day
Starbucks is like we're banning all the
pride stuff and now you start seeing
these little they're putting little
breadcrumbs out man little breadcrumbs
oh I saw this one thing in Chicago oh
yeah illegal immigrants are upset about
where they're staying and these illegal
immigrants who speak no English are
holding up perfectly written English
signs saying we're tired of how we're
being treated and now you're starting to
see this over and over again so
everyone's always like when when all
these Republican Governors are like
sending these these immigrants all over
the country and it's like yeah you're
showing those Democrats bro they're
sets I know it sounds crazy but that is
one 100 what is percent what do you mean
they're moving assets dude these guys
coming into the country bro have you
seen them a lot of them are Chinese and
a lot of them are military Russian
people and I'm telling you they're
moving and this is what's going to be
right around 2024 election immigration
riots people going nuts and it as as
listen to this and you'll start seeing
all the little breadcrumbs being put up
may I give you another scenario no I
give you another possible scenario I
hate to piss on your parade what if we
do have open borders thank you Joe Biden
and and a complete disaster down the
border and so Governors like Greg Abbott
are going not how about you guys want a
taste of what we're dealing with hey New
York here you go they bust 13 000
immigrants New York Eric Adams goes we
don't have the resources yeah Brian and
that's a good way to teach the blue
states to change their border yeah
that's what they want you so that's how
you get into this is Brian look I'm a
puppet master I'm telling you
but I just wanted to get that out to
everybody because I'm trying to warn
people this is what's next